danke florian bauer ja es ist nicht mehr
und nicht weniger als das
ordnungspolitische glaubensbekenntnis
der bundesregierung so hat das
handelsblatt dieser tage den
jahreswirtschaftsbericht
geschrieben es ist der erste den der
bundesminister für wirtschaft und
klimaschutz robert habeck vorliegt er
ist abgestimmt natürlich auch mit
anderen ressorts und das hat durchaus
die ein und andere implikationen gehabt
gleich also wie gesagt schon und wie sie
gehört vor allem auch die
regierungserklärung dazu es wird mit
diskutiert werden in diesem zusammenhang
auch der bericht der jahresbericht der
wirtschaftsweisen zudem anträge aus der
afg und aus der linksfraktion und es
gibt glaube ich wenn ich jetzt das
richtige parat habe auch einen
entschließungsantrag der unionsfraktion
dazu also jede menge zu diskutieren
heute morgen um 9 aber ein paar
eckpunkte zumindest waren wir vorher
schon erörtern und ich freue mich dass
dazu da sind gesine lötzsch die
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
linksfraktion ihnen einen schönen guten
morgen und dieter janitschek ist ja der
wirtschaftspolitische sprecher der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen der titel
der regierungserklärung nicht des
jahreswirtschaftsbericht der titel der
regierungserklärung ist transformation
gestalten der ordnungsrahmen klima
gericht fortentwickeln herr janitschek
das klingt ein bisschen weit reichend
aber auch ein wenig sperrig sagen sie
uns mal ganz anschaulich worum es geht
und was das zentrale anliegen dieses
jahreswirtschaftsberichts ist ja die
ziele sind ja auch weit reichend wir
wollen die soziale marktwirtschaft
erweitern zu einer sozial ökologischen
marktwirtschaft dh den klimaschutz mit
der wirtschaft verbinden und vorteile
für beide seiten generieren und dafür
wollen wir große investitionen
voranbringen 60 milliarden euro in dem
energie und klima vor der jetzt
aufgelegt wurde und das heißt wir geben
ein signal für die unternehmen aber auch
für die verbraucher dass wir jetzt
marode infrastrukturen sei es im bereich
der öffentlichen daseinsvorsorge aber
insbesondere auch was industrie und den
wandel richtung klimaneutralität geht
voran bringen signale wie ich gestern
auch noch mal nachgefragt habe die die
wirtschaft dringlich erwartet auch was
wir was die investitionen angeht und
überhaupt auch planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren und ähnliches
rolle die union sagt das sei kein
jahreswirtschaftsbericht sondern ein
weiterer nachhaltigkeitsbericht alle
inhalte würden ökologischen zielen
untergeordnet was ihre bewertung über
details reden wir noch im laufe der
nächsten zehn minuten also ich glaube
das hauptproblem ist dass man ja von
einer sozialen marktwirtschaft zu einer
sozialen ökologischen übergehen will und
sich die frage stellen muss ob soziale
marktwirtschaft für viele menschen in
unserem land überhaupt noch erlebt da
ist wir haben jetzt als ergebnis der
pandemie aber auch der entwicklung
vorjahr eine enorme verteilungs krise
viele menschen haben geringe einkommen
minijobber mini rentner und ohne diese
verteilungs krise zu lösen also ohne
mehr sozialer gerechtigkeit ohne mehr
verteilungsgerechtigkeit werden wir auch
die ökologische krise nicht lösen also
zu viel ökologie als ziel drin ist oder
wie man muss das verbinden man kann die
ökologische krise nicht lösen wenn man
die soziale krise löst verbinden sie ist
nicht hinreichend ich werde gleich mal
fortführen noch weil es sei ja nicht nur
das wachstums kriterium eine
entscheidende rolle spielen also des
wachstums kriterium wie sich
wiederfindet dem bruttoinlandsprodukt
der janacek sondern es sollen weitere
faktoren dazu kommen also sogenannte
wohlfahrts und
nachhaltigkeitsindikatoren auch wieder
so begriffen wo man erst mal ein
bisschen nachlassen muss was wofür steht
das eigentlich helfen sie uns ja wir
wollen schon was verändern das heißt
auch die art und weise wie wir wohlstand
messen wollen wir verändern das heißt
sie haben zu recht gesagt soziale
indikatoren müssen in einer wohlfahrts
oder einer wohlstands messung auch
wirklich sichtbar sein die frage der
sozialen ungleichheit der herkunft bei
bildung aber eben auch der ökologische
fußabdruck das probieren wir jetzt zum
ersten mal das wird auch noch ausgebaut
und erweitert in diesem
jahreswirtschaftsbericht aber natürlich
geht es auch im kern ganz hart jetzt um
die fragen wie geht es weiter mit der
industrie mit den lieferketten mit den
corona helfen all das wird auch in der
debatte nach eine große rolle spielen da
hätte ich trotzdem gerne noch mal ein
bisschen konkreter erläutert bislang
sagen wir bruttoinlandsprodukt bemisst
sich an den erbrachten dienstleistungen
an den hergestellten gütern und waren
jetzt wollen sie andere faktoren dazu
und sie haben ein bisschen angedeutet
sagen sie das noch mal konkreter und
sagen sie mal vor allem wie daraus eine
sogenannte kenngröße entstehen soll wie
das bruttoinlandsprodukt ja auch genannt
wird nachdem der politiker maria wird
das bruttoinlandsprodukt bleibt dir
erhalten auch als kenngröße das ist auch
für die ökonomen auch für uns wichtig
dass wir einfach wissen ist der güter
umlauf welche entwicklung gibt es auf
verschiedenen sektor märkten auf der
anderen seite haben wir aber in der
vergangenheit eine situation gehabt wo
wachstum nicht automatisch bedeutet hat
dass menschen sozial besser abgesichert
waren beispielsweise dass jobs auch
entsprechende löhne hatten dass menschen
in jobs kamen die mit denen sie auch
leben konnten wurde das im grunde das
was rot ja auch aggressiv auch
wahrscheinlich haben wir in
einzelbereichen dann auch differenzen
wie weit man gehen muss und natürlich
die große frage dass das
bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt hat beim
klimaschutz muss jetzt eine regierung
auch in der wirtschaftspolitik bei den
investitionen handeln weil wir das
verbinden müssen das heißt
wirtschaftliches handeln muss auch
nachhaltigkeit implizieren und das muss
ich jetzt konsequent in seinem
jahreswirtschaftsbericht auch
wiederfinden
was fehlt er macht ja die spectrum wird
deutlich erweitert
die frage ist nur ist es sind das schöne
beschreibung ist kosmetik oder ist es
wirklich handeln fragen will in dortmund
für mich ist die entscheidende frage
dass ich wirklich die verteilungs krise
auch dass die vierte löst wird und wir
haben ja eine situation dass in unserem
land das einkommen die vermögen
ungeheuer ungleich verteilt sind 45
deutsche besitzen so viel wie die
gesamte ärmere hälfte der bevölkerung
und diese verteilungs krise hängt
natürlich auch die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung und die weniger leute ein
gutes einkommen haben desto mehr können
sie zum beispiel auch in der
binnennachfrage dazu beitragen dass sich
die wirtschaft weiter entwickelt und wir
sehen auch was den ökologischen
fußabdruck betrifft das ist im
augenblick noch sehr sehr ungerecht
zugeht denn menschen mit dem geringsten
einkommen haben auch den kleinsten
ökologischen fußabdruck müssen aber hohe
kosten tragen wir haben jetzt die
situation dass die gegner die preise
enorm gestiegen sind und da ist das
wichtigste aus meiner sicht dass wir
wieder zu einer staatlichen
preiskontrolle kommen natürlich kann
muss man kurzfristig ausgleichen durch
zuschüsse für die ärmsten die das nicht
finanzieren können aber das darf nicht
zu einer weiteren umverteilung auf
kosten der steuerzahler ein steuerzahler
führen sondern da brauchen wir wirklich
endlich wieder preis deckelung und
staatliche energiekunden preiskontrolle
gerne direkt dazu also wir sind eher
skeptisch was jetzt eine preis steuerung
auf den energiemärkten angeht sehr wohl
haben wir bei maßnahmen ergriffen zb was
das thema wohngeld angeht für
wohngeldbezieher innen dass wir dort
auch jetzt eingegriffen haben im sinne
von ersten zahlungen und die auch
notwendig sind hier um sozialen
ausgleich zu schaffen die eeg-umlage
wird entweder zum ersten 120 123 oder
vielleicht sogar schon früher
abgeschafft das heißt hier wird eine
senkung des strompreises geben davon
werden auch verbraucher profitieren und
wir haben als grüne fraktion ja auch den
vorschlag unterbreitet ein klima geld
einzuführen das heißt insbesondere dann
auch dass die ärmeren in der
gesellschaft und auch davon profitieren
dass wir das geld was wir auf der co2
seite einnehmen das ist ja auch da dass
wir das zurückgeben aber es ist richtig
das muss jetzt auch kommen da muss jetzt
auch gehandelt werden in den nächsten
monaten und jahren der soziale und
ökologische umbau das muss einhergehen
und das darf nicht gegeneinander laufen
die abschätzung der eeg-umlage das
begrüßen wir natürlich aber dann
verbinden wir natürlich die forderung
damit dass
abgesichert werden muss dass die großen
energiekonzernen keinen mitnahmeeffekt
haben und sagen da stecken wir uns jetzt
ein und deshalb unsere forderung
natürlich nach einer wiedereinführung
der staatlichen preiskontrolle ansatz
wird es nicht funktionieren jetzt
die frage die ich tatsächlich auch hatte
und diese hier angesprochen haben wird
das geht es dann tatsächlich irgendwie
zugunsten dann auch der verbraucherinnen
und verbraucher aus da haben wir eine
vergangenheit die erfahrung gemacht dass
das nicht automatisch der fall gewesen
sind auch wenn der staat macht gegeben
hat bei bei steuern und abgaben haben
dass die unternehmen trotzdem meinen
behalten und unser eine hatte nichts
davon das ist der eine punkt wo sie noch
mal ein bisschen klarheit schaffen
könnten und der andere ist wie konkret
ist es denn überhaupt das ganze vorhaben
dass diese die abschaffung der
eeg-umlage tatsächlich vorzuziehen ich
höre das auch natürlich immer was passt
ja jetzt gerade auch in die in die
preissteigerung debatte und die
steigenden energiepreise aber wie
konkret arbeiten sie da eigentlich dran
auch als koalition wenn man muss ja ein
bisschen differenzieren was die
verbraucherinnen verbraucher
insbesondere aus ärmeren haushalten
brauchen und ich sag jetzt mal auch ein
bisschen flapsig was die industrie uns
erzählt was sie braucht nicht alle
vorschläge aus der lobbyisten zum muss
man eins zu eins umsetzen
insofern ist es auch ein bisschen mehr
marktwirtschaft wagen in dem punkt zu
sagen ja wir brauchen entlastungen für
die menschen die es brauchen aber wir
brauchen nicht zwingend in jeder
erhöhung von energiepreis situationen da
eine entlastung für breite teile auch
der wirtschaft oder auch das gehobene
mittelstand ist und da muss man
unterscheiden weil wenn wir jetzt sofort
sehr viel geld ausgeben in der breite
dann fehlt uns das am ende am anderen
ende so das ist die diskussion die eeg
umlage werden wir abschaffen das ist
vereinbart im koalitionsvertrag frage
ist nur noch der stichtag und wann das
überhaupt geht da gibt's nämlich auch
vorlagen wer es lieber geld was ich
angesprochen das hat mit nicht
vereinbart schon deshalb nicht so gut
wie wie konkret ist eigentlich ist dass
es tatsächlich vorgezogen wird und wie
konkret daran gearbeitet wird das ist
weiß ich nicht mitte des jahres so dabei
noch immer was hast du denn da ins auge
ich persönlich und auch für meine
fraktion bin zurückhaltend dass wir da
jetzt ein sehr schnellen schritt gehen
weil wenn sie jetzt die eeg-umlage sehr
früh
abschaffen dann heißt das auch dass wir
aus ätherisch dann ja einige milliarden
weniger haben dann zehn tagen auswerten
bitte zehn ungefähr habe ich gelesen ja
also die frage wird sein was wir wollen
und ich habe einen schwerpunkt auf das
thema klima geld das wir auch
artikulieren wird innerhalb der
koalition zu sagen wir wollen jetzt
gezielt entlasten wir wollen die
eeg-umlage abschaffen aber dann bitte in
einem gemeinsamen schritt zum ersten
ersten 2023 hochzeit ist ein gutes
stichwort da ist mir ja wirklich sehr
schwer im magen und fliegt mir immer
noch schwer im magen dass sich die fdp
sehr gut durchgesetzt hat also die
schuldenbremse ist ja etwas was
ökonomisch völlig unsinnig ist und
natürlich auch die öffentlichen
investitionen hemd und die grünen haben
ja vor der wahl immer gesagt also so
geht das mit der schuldenbremse nicht
weiter jetzt hat sich erstmal die fdp
durchgesetzt mit herrn lindner und ich
kann die grünen und natürlich auch die
spd ab jetzt steht er in grüner neben
mir nur auffordern sich das nicht weiter
bestehen zu lassen denn wir haben ja
gesehen dass wir öffentliche
investitionen brauchen und wenn wir
nicht genug einnahmen haben dann können
wir diese öffentlichen investitionen
noch nicht realisieren und was die
unternehmen betrifft ist mir auch ganz
wichtig darauf hinzuwirken dass die
unternehmen selber investieren die
investitionen die die unternehmen
tätigen sind wirklich immer weiter
abgesunken die gewinne werden nicht mehr
so investiert wie vielleicht vor 25
jahren
sondern es gibt ausschüttungen und das
ist finde ich nicht indem wir in dieser
situation
es gibt forderungen aus der industrie
sie haben das ja auch angesprochen und
dass man nicht jeder folgen kann aber
ich glaube hier muss man viel strikter
vorgehen und unternehmens
steuersenkungen wie sie herr lindner ins
auge gefasst hat die sind überhaupt
nicht hinnehmbar und da sollten die
grünen auch aus den fehlern ihrer ersten
regierungszeit mit gerd schröder lernen
denn damals wurden die
unternehmensteuern so gesenkt und
darunter leiden wir heute noch wir
können oder wir müssen den grünen sogar
fragen wie viel grün oder wie viel
weniger grün denn in diesen
tatsächlichen jahreswirtschaftsbericht
noch drin ist im vergleich zu dem etwa
auf der im dezember bekanntgeworden ist
es hat einige formulierungen deutliche
formulierung änderungen gegeben haben
freundlicherweise die kolleginnen und
kollegen vom handelsblatt herausgefunden
beispielsweise was formulierungen angeht
stadt ordnungsrahmen klima gerecht
fortentwickeln ist jetzt nur noch die
rede für sozial ökologische
marktwirtschaft also es gibt ja durchaus
unterschiedliche vorstellungen zwischen
ihnen und der fdp das wirtschafts
politik angeht sie ordnungspolitische
natürlich sehr viel sehr viel klarer die
der fdp betonte in liberale und betonten
im markt und da gibt es auch noch eine
formulierung die hier deutlich abweicht
im vergleich zur ersten version nämlich
dass der marktwirtschaftliche prozess
aus sich heraus zu einem sozial
ausgewogenen wachstum führt er ist
glaube ich auch nicht mehr drin also wie
viel haben sie preisgegeben ich glaube
das ist ein bericht der noch sehr klar
dass formuliert dass wir jetzt auch eine
debatte nachher dann sagen werden
nämlich dass wir einen rahmen brauchen
der in richtung klimaschutz geht aber
eben auch soziale marktwirtschaft weiter
entwickelt dafür dass neue indikatoren
jetzt eingeführt werden um auch den
wohlstand neu zu messen und damit auch
signale bei bildung bei sozialer
ungleichheit zu geben und natürlich hat
man im ressort prinzip dann in der
abstimmung mit anderen immer auch noch
diskussionen zu berücksichtigen das ist
so aber sie können schon davon ausgehen
dass das heute ein sehr kraftvoller
aufschlag wird richtung
jahreswirtschaftsbericht richtung grüner
und auch soziale wirtschaftspolitik in
der zukunft gestrichen worden ist der
satz scheitern der unsichtbaren hand des
marktes zurück genommen auch gerne an
generell ist eine generelle kritik am
wachstum im großen und ganzen also da
ist hat sich die fdp oder zumindest das
finanzministerium noch deutlich
durchgesetzt also robert hable kantig
formulieren das ja auch so dass wir
durchaus wachstum brauchen und zwar in
den bereichen wo das absolut notwendig
ist bei den erneuerbaren energien
brauchen wir ein drastisches wachstum
in der zukunft ziele zu erreichen wir
werden höheren stromverbrauch haben das
ist alles definiert also ist die
wachstums debatte insofern abstrakt dass
es doch darum gehen muss dass der
ressourcenverbrauch absinkt aber
gleichzeitig wie natürlich auch um für
soziale umverteilung dann entsprechende
mittel zu haben die mittel auch
generieren müssen und dieses prinzip
bleibt auch erhalten aber wir wollen den
wachstumsbegriff erweitern um die frage
es muss verträglich seien in richtung
klimaschutz und es muss vor allem
verträglich seien in richtung soziale
gerechtigkeit die frage bleibe ich
wieder selbst durchsetzen können das
wären wir sehen und beobachten ich hoffe
ein bisschen zeit habe sie dürfen sogar
bei mir fehlt natürlich völlig eine
perspektive für ostdeutschland das ist
überhaupt nicht berücksichtigt und wir
sind ja jetzt im wievielten jahr kann
man schon gar nicht mehr nach zählen der
deutschen einheit und da erwarte ich
dass da entschieden nachgebessert wird
und das ist natürlich auch eine
internationale frage denn die sanktionen
gegen russland treffen vor allem wegen
wirtschaftlich aus deutschland und hier
braucht es einen ausgleich und an dieser
stelle müssen wir dieses gespräch leider
beenden werden viele punkte gleich noch
mal wieder hören in der debatte frau
lötzsch vielen dank dass ich heute
morgen bei uns gewesen sind auch in der
janacek wir haben einiges gar nicht
besprechen können beispielsweise die
interessante diskussion über die
streichung von kfw förderung für
energetische sanieren und bauen gerade
in diesen tagen auch ein eine heikle
debatte dass das nicht zustande gekommen
ist sie müssen reingehen und ich muss
langsam rüber geben inspirieren und
danke sie dürfen auch geben